all right one last topic before we go
2019 is a target for the nfl to get a
new collective bargaining agreement in
place the league would like to have it
in place before the start of the regular
season i don't think that's practical i
think best case scenario is to have a
new cba in place before the next super
bowl but be that as it may a term to get
accustomed to because you're going to
hear a lot of it as these negotiations
heat up and as proposals begin to be
exchanged by the nfl players association
and the national football league and the
phrase is this
stadium credits see ultimately at the
core of any cba between the nfl and the
nfl pa is how they split up the money
now before 2011 the players were getting
60
that sounds good but it was 60 of the
net after the owners took a lot of money
off of the top for all sorts of other
things
now the players are getting under the
2011 cba roughly 47
of the gross well moving forward what
owners would like to do is take more
money off the top to help pay for
construction and renovation of stadiums
and the players look at it and they say
why don't we want to be in that business
the owners provide the workplace we
provide the work why should we be paying
with money that otherwise would be
distributed to all players through the
salary cap mechanism
money that uh is gonna go to pay for the
stadiums that's not our deal that's not
our gig here's the problem the owners
may be intent on pushing that issue
aggressively enough that they would lock
the players out over it so if the owners
are serious about it and they want some
allowance for stadium credits what do
the players do here's one way to look at
it
if you're the players
and the league expects you to chip in
for the renovation and construction of
stadiums specifically as it relates to
the construction of stadiums the players
need a say
in where these stadiums are going to be
constructed that creates a a fascinating
new dynamic
as we look at
the game of stadium construction and
whether or not teams will relocate if
they can't get the kind of public money
they want and does it make business
sense to build a new stadium in a small
market when there's a bigger market out
there where everyone can make more money
and and now should the players if
they're going to be paying for the
stadiums
should they have a seat at the table
when it comes to those deliberations as
to where
nfl stadiums should be constructed look
at buffalo and folks i i know bills fans
get very very sensitive to any
suggestion that there may not be a new
stadium built in buffalo and that the
stadium where the bills play at some
point could be built somewhere else but
think about this if the nfl pa is going
to be expected to devote a chunk of
money that otherwise would go to players
to construction of a new bills stadium
shouldn't the nflpa have a say in
whether or not that stadium is built in
buffalo or somewhere else maybe
collectively the players don't want to
live and work in buffalo no offense to
buffalo but if the players don't want to
live and work there and they're
partially paying for the stadium
maybe that ends up being a factor in how
this all plays out i guess my point is
for the nfl be careful what you wish for
because
if you want players to contribute to the
construction of stadiums you have to
give them a voice you can't just say we
blindly want the money and we'll figure
out how to use it best and if you do
give them a voice how do you keep them
from basically hijacking the process and
saying you know what
we'd rather have a team in st louis st
louis is putting together some public
money it's going to cost us less and you
less and we're going to make more money
in st louis because it's a bigger market
than buffalo
i think if you open that door
and the players become partners
not just in the sport specifically but
in how the sport is presented via that
construction of stadiums
things could get
intriguing to say the least
and
all of a sudden instead of what the
owner wants because that's what it's
always been what's the owner want the
owner wants to stay the owner wants to
move the owner wants this the owner
wants that the players are kicking in
significant money for these stadiums
significant enough money that maybe they
would be locked out if they refuse to
kick in the money
and they get a voice
maybe players start dictating where
teams are going to be
and the more i think about it
i
i wonder why it hasn't been that case in
the past why is it that the people who
own the teams decide where the teams are
going to be why isn't it that the
players the ones who have to live and
work in those communities don't have
more of a say
if you expect the players to pay
for
a large chunk of the new stadiums that
are going to be built maybe they should
have that say and maybe this could get a
lot more interesting as these talks
unfold if stadium credits continue to be
an issue and i believe based upon
everything i've heard there will be a
major issue in this ongoing round of cba
negotiations
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports